twitch plays streams are nothing new but
the latest one surly is different I'm
Dave and welcome to your battery
draining news update twitch plays
pokemon seas viewers controlling the
game by submitting commands through the
channels chat room pokemon go is an
augmented reality game that requires
someone to venture onto the real world
with the phone to track down pokemon
though those in chat are able to dictate
whether player moves on the twitch plays
pokemon faq they stated that they
started playing in central park new york
city where they are now is anyone's
guess he adds that the location is
spoofed so it sounds as if someone isn't
physically navigating the world probably
for the best safety wise further
complicating things is the fact that the
game is played on a touchscreen twitch
plays games are typically played with
the controller so for this the screen
has to be split up into a grid commands
entered by specifying what area of the
screen chat members want them to touch
how long this will run for remains to be
seen developer niantic could step in to
do something about hacks being used to
simulate the players location those
running the channel are aware of this
possibility stating if niantic or
Nintendo wishes to ban the account that
which is playing with they're more than
welcome to but we assume that they
understand that this is all in good fun
so what do you think about the Pokemon
go sensation are you out and about
looking for Pikachu's or do you think
this game is just too far fetched let us
know in the comments section below or
find me on Twitter at a regular Dave and
for all your Pokemon news stay tuned to
gamespot com